hello and welcome to this video planks
meta 0 8 i'm not really really know what
is usually playing a clayton quite a bit
but no particular memory so let's see we
probably will gather and i QP position
the capture now and define Bishop e7 is
the most popular way of playing this
taking a bit of time then you don't have
to take on before early on but
[Music]
I'm not sure how this is clay drilling
that b6 looks like it may be possible so
I'm not taking the bishop it looks
better for wider it takes to the night
that was pretty awkward pin
so what to do 95s may be coming
[Music]
yeah again retreating this voluntarily
right if I've at least we should see
eight now yeah this is the thing I can
try this sound like I go back at equals
g5 look a bit crazy but maybe g5g for
Toronto ok it doesn't do it try to win
the pawn so now is the bishop when I'm
developing now in our queen these three
looks dangerous
cam Fisher f6 is a threat but I know
what a groupie aight really health
you what else they cannot play g6 or
something like that its root liate
failing to something that I don't see
you yeah this is this is how to believe
so if I sacrifice he has 25 at the end
so 95 takes Bishop takes 95 threatening
on g2 now maybe I can do something like
Queen g3 but if I just play this and
play normal rules isn't this a pretty
awful weakening of the position okay
night before as the idea and maybe g4s
also on the cards gee 495 24 night x 6
is a piece i can go in 3g for like if
I've night text before I just don't
believe I mean I just assume that this
doesn't work so maybe this one
yet hope for some reason it holds as bad
as it looks it holds okay if I take it
nice size maybe this is something simple
that i can do just them I mean you
cannot take it 97 as a threat maybe
that's not not a bad choice maybe loop
the aid you know OOP th can take twice
on g650 for saying so this is not
[Music]
decisive yeah what you want to do here
cannot take six unfortunately i wonder
if i should just take just keep the pawn
and let's just keep the pawn just try to
do that
so he's got this bad structure but other
than that is ok not to sell too bad
okay I can just take it for better
ending or Queen to e5 but check when the
better ending is fairly tempting yeah
just keep the pawn and see if I can do
stuff route to check kv-5 a success much
not bad not a bad spot to beam check
check time warning
I wanted to go get 6 which doesn't help
all that much okay okay I can't engage
6am okay i see pawn is going to be
dangerous I just got two seconds black
for that sometime okay I can win on time
once in a while yeah it was still not
not that good yeah i mean that that
position looks just lost also really bad
for black after g5 and I couldn't really
couldn't really get anywhere Luke takes
is 6mm something I should have seen
really pretty extend the tactical idea
but it don't leave the win yahoo p8d
hangs on come home okay come out black
holes is a pawn down but it's not lost
in this position is just is just
slightly better for white why why why
White has the pair of bishops is got
weaknesses all over the place and it's
not really that great amazing in the air
that somehow is still ok for lucky
AgForce it'll search lineups not helping
but ok mr. Lance oh that's nothing
nothing special well screwing up the
window still nothing special at the end
that one on time there's a final
positions anything is over you can check
can very much you respect is v1 equal
ish equal ish yeah okay the time was the
most decisive factor you okay thanks for
watching